de curieux remous dans des eaux obscures
au Port-Marly ce mardi 11 juillet un
drone sous-marin nouvelle génération
était expérimentée dans la scène
généralement utilisé en milieu marin sur
vos permet d'analyser la qualité de
l'eau grâce à son collecteur doté de 8
moteurs d'un éclairage frontal et d'une
caméra l'opérateur peut scruter les
profondeurs au moyen d'une télécommande
au fait de la collecte de données pures
ça peut paraître
jouet on peut se dire bon voilà bon cela
dit c'est des très très gros jouets de
par leur simplicité d'opérabilité mais
ça reste quand même des extraordinaires
extraordinaires outils de collecte de
données dans l'élément haut en gardant
les pieds hauts secs
donc elle était à la coque des bateaux
les vannes de l'éclus dans quel état
elles sont comment vous le savoir il
faut plonger il faut être des plongeurs
ça coûte cher là le drone c'est la
caméra il le fil il vous ramène ça à la
surface et là j'avance comme ça et
ensuite je peux plonger voilà je
descends c'était est organisé pour
illustrer un appel à projet lancé par la
Communauté d'Agglomération Saint-Germain
boucle de Seine association laboratoire
au startup l'objectif est d'inviter tout
type de structure à proposer des
solutions pour dépolluer la scène et son
écosystème mais on sera attentif en
réalité à toutes les initiatives celles
qui permettent d'avoir des résultats
rapides comme celle qui permet d'avoir
des résultats à l'horizon plus lointain
mais des résultats puissants il appelle
à projet est lancé jusqu'au 31 juillet
prochain les lauréats pourront
bénéficier d'un terrain
d'expérimentation grandeur nature pour
leur solution les sports de refaire de
la scène dans les prochaines années un
lieu de vie pour les populations
avoisinantes